coffee on the Tresa wait where am I wait
McGriddle why the lever
Thanksgiving time when we celebrate all
were thankful for a time for family good
food a time to relax with a good
football game and some beers the holiday
can be traced to a feast in 1621 on
Plymouth Plantation in Massachusetts a
good harvest year due in part to the
corn growing skills taught to the
settlers by Squanto upon tucks it into
quote Edward Winslow
and although would be not always so
plentiful as it was at this time with us
yet by the goodness of God we are so far
from one that we often wish you
partakers of our plenty it's at this
time of year that I'm often reminded of
Robert De Niro's great comeback movie of
2009 everybody's fine what is it just
tell me the truth
died
no I'm that's no trouble tell me that's
not true
I'm sorry moved out of his apartment
what the hell is this I just wanted to
talk about hello you're saying that I
can't talk about Bobby De Niro's great
comeback roll 2009 oh yo there's a bill
in the House of Representatives right
now called the Stop Online Piracy Act or
so not many people know about it but
those of us who have one of our
Horcruxes are online know that the
internet is angry why are they angry
well it's because many of them believe
that this bill SOPA which the house is
very quickly and quietly trying to push
through to passing represents an
infringement on their basic rights of
free speech let's take a minute to
understand what sofa is and how it
worked private companies namely large
corporations within the entertainment
industry the Motion Picture Association
of America the Recording Industry
Association of America
Netflix Viacom the ability to shut down
on unauthorized rogue sites where people
download TV shows music and movie now
they already have the right to do this
under American copyright law on an
individual basis you may have seen this
screen before but a lot of these sites
operate from outside the US and so
aren't in its jurisdiction so will will
allow the government to force us
internet providers to block access to
domain names that carry this Conn
corporations could also sue under SOPA
any search engine that lists these sites
in their result or any blog or form that
provides the link to but sofa has
another one this law gives corporations
and the government the ability to choke
the funding of websites by forcing
advertisers and payment services paypal
mastercard visa from doing business with
them from the time the claim is filed
the service would have five days to
sever its ties to the infringing website
or risk persecution what do you think
payment service providers will do given
the choice its economic submission an
internet death but now copyright law is
certainly important and compensation
should be provided to artists who sell
their work under copyright they deserve
to be protect the problem with SOPA is
that though protection is its stated aim
the law won't be effective against
content piracy for example you'll still
be able to access blocked sites by
entering the IP address instead of the
domain but that's not all SOPA might
actually work against its purpose
there's the thing you never heard of
called the domain name system security
extensions or DNS SEC provides
end-to-end encryption of domain name
making sure
that there's no break in the chain
between say Citizens Bank and its custom
forcing internet providers to redirect
allegedly piratical sites to FBI servers
is incompatible with that Cisco's
experts believe that tampering with the
Internet's registry of domain names will
result in less security not more the
fact is that hackers and pirates have
always had a way of finding cracks and
circumventing laws despite efforts to
stop what many fear about sofa is its
potential to curb and discourage
innovation in our most innovative
industry digital marketplace of ideas
that welcomes every blog and tweet is
the same one that inspires the next
generation of innovators to fuel our
economy well give corporations the
ability to target startups new search
engines or new social media platforms if
they feel that their filtering isn't
good one lawsuit to a small fledgling
company is usually all that it takes
even established sites like Tumblr
YouTube SoundCloud and Facebook could
come under the gun any amount of illegal
content could be enough to temporarily
shut down the entire site and violators
like that little baby who likes biggie
or that guy who makes awesome acapella
audio dress
these people could face jail
don't send babies to jail representative
Lamar Smith from Texas announced the
legislation last month and it has
bipartisan support also has bipartisan
opposition on this issue Nancy Pelosi
and Ron Paul are on the same saga
Facebook Twitter zinga zinga eBay
Mozilla Yahoo AOL and LinkedIn issued an
open letter to key members of Congress
last week stating that SOPA was quote a
serious risk to our industries continued
track of innovation and job creation as
well as to our nation's cyber secure and
it should be noted that the MPAA for
example is a relatively tiny workforce
when you compare it to the jobs created
by the inner I put links to petitions
and information on what representatives
you can call in the doobly now there's a
provision in American copyright law
called fair use it grants an exception
to copyrighted material for the purposes
of commentary criticism news reporting
research here are the four factors used
to determine whether or not use is fair
the purpose and character of the use
including whether such use is of a
commercial nature or is for non-profit
educational purposes the nature of the
copyrighted work the amount and
substantiality of the portion used in
relation to the copyrighted work as a
whole and the effect or use upon the
potential market so what about my use of
Robert De Niro's great comeback movie of
2009 everybody's fine was it fair okay
one purpose and character well I'm using
the clip to make a point for completely
nonprofit purpose to the nature of the
work well it's a Hollywood movie it's
gross
sixty million four hundred fifty four
thousand eight hundred and fifty dollars
its budget twenty million so I'm helping
still on DVD okay number three the
amount used okay so I used thirty-eight
seconds
divide that by the runtime of ninety
nine minutes and you get my use of point
zero zero zero six three six percent
finally number four the effect on
potential market did you ever hear of
this movie before I mentioned is still
on DVD it's plain to see why fair use is
critically important in our age we are
now a community of autodidact taking the
vast soup of information and
consolidating it into coherent stories
this is how we learn today this is how
we teach each other this is how we start
a revolution or take a stand or figure
out where our efforts can be put to the
best you this Thanksgiving I'm grateful
for fair use
brought a full-circle baby I'm also
grateful for friends and family and
speaking of I have to get out of here
dammit miscalculate okay okay yeah
that's more like